مع وجود العديد من المشاهير في Met Gala
يرتدون ملابس مثل قطة المصمم كارل
لاغرفيلد ، من المدهش أن يتجرأ
صرصور على تسريع السجادة الحمراء ،
لكن هناك كان يعامل مثل أحد
المشاهير يحصل على صورة كيفن يحصل على
مجموعة متنوعة من الصور التقطها مصور جيتي وهو يعمي
صرصور مع وميضه
صرصور جعل الناس يطلقون عليه اسم
النجم المفاجئ في حفل Met Gala لعام 2023 ،
ووصفه الآخرون بأنه الأفضل لباسًا وتكهنوا
بأصله ، لكنه
خرج من زي سبايس آيس سبايس ،
فقد وصل متأخراً بشكل عصري إلى الظهور
قبل الضيفة الأخيرة ريهانا بشكل طبيعي.  كان على
شخص ما أن يسأل عن لباسه ما الذي
ترتديه ولكن الموضة كانت
موضوعًا لن يطرحه هذا الصرصور ، فقد اختفى
فقط للظهور مرة أخرى في
الدرابزين الذي كنت تعتقد أنه كان عبارة عن طوافة
بدلاً من صرصور بالطريقة التي رد بها الحشد
المصور كيفن مازور  في وقت من الأوقات
تظاهر مازحًا بالدوس عليه
ثم ركله عن طريق الخطأ ولكن
ذلك لم يوقفه ثم غردت مجموعة متنوعة من
الأخبار المقلقة ، إنه بحزن
عميق يجب علينا الإبلاغ عن أن
صرصور Met Gala قد داس عليه وبالتالي
هل ينضم  أخطاء أخرى تأتي من
القطاع الصحي
المقدس ، لقد ابتلعت للتو الإيقاع الذي
ضحى بحياتهم بشكل لطيف جدًا على الملأ ،
وسوف نتذكرك أنك مصمم
أزياء على قدم وساق مع باناش
محطم على السجادة الحمراء جينيموس سي إن إن
نيويورك